y reformulado el teorema de stocks allí
lo puse aquí en verde y lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es asegurarnos de
que estamos orientando de forma correcta
cuando recorremos nuestra curva que es
la frontera de alguna superficie porque
cuando pensamos en un vector normal a
una superficie de hecho pues podemos no
encontrar solución o de hecho hay una
infinidad de pero bueno si nos
restringimos a aquellos vectores
normales que tienen norma o no en
realidad sólo tenemos dos de ellos por
ejemplo voy a voy a dibujar les aquí un
par de ellos puede ser que en este punto
de aquí digamos este punto sobre la
superficie yo pueda encontrar este
vector normal unitario a la superficie
pero no sólo eso porque también yo puedo
encontrar un vector normal pero éste
apuntará hacia adentro es decir algo así
de esta forma
entonces lo que quiero hacer déjenme
hacerlo más claro
ok está algo así este vector que apunta
hacia adentro entonces tenemos dos
vectores normales tenemos que pensar en
una convención correcta para poder
utilizar el teorema de 'stocks' entonces
por ejemplo esta curva yo la puedo
recorrer ya sea en el sentido contrario
a las manecillas del reloj que sería
algo de esta forma es decir así estoy
recorriendo lo en el sentido contrario a
las manecillas del reloj o bien vamos a
quitar esto podríamos orientarlo de
forma al revés no es decir en el sentido
que recorren las manecillas del reloj
entonces cuál es la convención correcta
bueno supongamos supongamos que tomamos
este vector normal unitario sin perdón
vamos a
este vector normal unitario el que
apunta digamos hacia fuera de esta
superficie
entonces la convención es la siguiente
imagínense que nosotros vamos a ir
corriendo a lo largo de esta curva
entonces tenemos que orientar nuestra
cabeza hacia donde apunta el vector
normal entonces aquí está mi cabecita
aquí me tienen a mí corriendo sale
ahí estoy yo en el detalle es que mi
cabeza tiene que apuntar justo en la
dirección hacia donde se encuentra el
vector normal unitario ahora hacia que
la hacia qué sentido voy a correr
yo voy a correr en el sentido de tal
suerte que mi lado izquierdo mi mano
izquierda siempre quede apuntando hacia
el interior de la curva entonces en este
sentido yo voy a empezar a recorrer la
trayectoria de esta forma ok entonces
esa es la convención cuando yo tengo
este vector normal unitario por ejemplo
si yo me tomara el vector que apunta
digamos hacia adentro de la superficie
es decir si que fuera como una cazuela
entonces yo tendría que orientar mi
cabeza tendría que orientar mi cabeza
esto va a ser un poquito difícil de ver
pero la cabeza está orientada hacia
abajo y ahora voy a correr de la misma
forma de la misma forma que mi lado
izquierdo esté apuntando hacia el
interior de la curva de la curva azul
esta curva azul que le voy a llamar
entonces si yo voy corriendo como le
hago para que el lado izquierdo mi lado
izquierdo quede viendo hacia dentro de
la curva pues tengo que correr en este
sentido ok entonces de esta forma es que
tenemos la convención para poder
utilizar el teorema de stocks es poner
la cabeza en dirección al vector normal
y orientar la trayectoria de tal suerte
que el interior quede a mi izquierda
siempre